the jurgen experience have you seen sour
grapes the docker battery uh no
uh yes parts of it i haven't seen the
home i haven't it's pretty amazing
that's what i keep hearing it's amazing
yeah that this guy
made fake wine that was supposed to be
these really expensive bottles and duped
all these
like real one
well so when i first heard about the
film i was
under the impression like i sat next to
that guy i was at a
was that a australian consulate wine
dinner
in beverly hills with peter geigo from
penfold sitting next to me
and that guy was sitting next to what is
that guy's name uh
sour grapes sour grapes the documentary
um ruby yeah so he
he was like i met that guy sat next to
him um i didn't buy any wine from him um
luckily but uh but you know i met him so
initially i was like
you know [ __ ] that guy for like duping
all these people but the thing that
they're
they're basically saying was that yeah
that aside yeah he [ __ ] a lot of
people up but
his ability to do what he was doing
to put these wines in bottle and mimic
what
uh the palette the just the nature the
color everything about it and being able
to duplicate the
the what's in the bottle to the point
where it would fool a psalm
he was like he's an alchemist like he
was really good at like
making it he wasn't just like putting
wine in a bottle and selling you the
bottle like
if you opened it and you tasted it you
thought you really thought it was that
wine you would go
that seems like a that seems like not a
great version of that wine but that's
that wine
oh so you could tell that it was
slightly off
in some cases that's that's did you try
any of this one no
no no god i would want to try it but
like they were just saying the guy
really was able to
uh get close to mimicking the pallets
and structures of these wines so that's
why
what's his name again brian rudy kumar
ruby kernowan or
here it's right here
mm-hmm
okay ready interesting so
how did this guy do this like if you
know
like if it's such a fine art to create a
great wine
and i know you i've tried the whole
thing is you're just
what he was doing you know and i'm just
i'm speculating on this i haven't seen
the film but what he was doing was just
to fool you right now
that wine might not last in that bottle
once
it's not gonna it's not gonna hold up
it's not the structure it's not the
structure of wine i mean he was
literally putting
dirt and things in to create that
initial impression so that when you
taste it
to investigate it you okay i think
that's what that is
and then you write the check and he's
like [ __ ]
episodes of the joe rogan experience are
now free on spotify
that's right they're free from september
1st to december 1st they're going to be
available everywhere but after december
1st they will only be
available on spotify but they will be
free that includes the video the video
will also be there
it'll also be free that's all we're
asking just go download spotify
much love